BOTTOM OF THE HOUR.
BUT FIRST MY OPEN.
THEY ARE A SHAMEFUL LOT.
A MOTLEY CRUE, PARADING AROUND
AS OUR REPRESENTATIVES.
BUT THEY ARE IN IT FOR
THEMSELVES.
I’M NOT THE ONLY ONE WHO FEELS
THIS WAY.
CONGRESS’ APPROVAL RATING AS
POLLED AS LOW AS -- AS 17% THIS
YEAR.
I’M SURPRISED IT’S THAT HIGH.
THEIR FEEBLE ATTEMPT TO LOOK
LIKE THEY ARE GOING TO HELP US
IS AS TRANSPARENT AND USELESS AS
THEY ARE.
BUT THIS WEEK TOPPED EVEN NANCY
PELOSI’S SHAMELESS I’M RICH AND
YOU ARE NOT THEATER AS SHE POSED
EATING ICE CREAM IN FRONT OF HER
$ -- 24,000 REFRIGERATOR
FREEZER.
SHE SAID IT HELPED HER DEAL WITH
THE PANDEMIC.
WHAT PANDEMIC.
THERE ARE NO RULES FOR YOU.
YOU CLAIM TO NOT UNDERSTAND WHY
PEOPLE ARE AGAINST LOCKDOWN
ORDERS.
YOUR COLD RESPONSE, SHELTER IN
PLACE IS REALLY THE ANSWER.
REALLY?
YOU PHONEY CONDESCENDING
FRAUDULENT HYPOCRITE.
AS YOU, THE MOST POWERFUL
ELECTED HOUSE DEMOCRAT
PONTIFICATE WE SIMPLY NEED TO
LISTEN TO THE SCIENCE.
YOU MARCH THROUGH A SALON
WITHOUT A MASK LIKE A QUEEN.
YOU AND YOUR ILK VIOLATE YOUR
OWN RULES SO OFTEN IT’S CLEAR,
YOU BELIEVE NOT ONLY THAT YOU
ARE ABOVE THE LAW, BUT ALSO THAT
THE RULES SERVE NO PURPOSE OTHER
THAN TO SUPPRESS AND DEFEAT US.
WHILE YOU AND CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM * SHUT US
DOWN.
YOU ARE CREATING AN UNNECESSARY
CLASS WAR.
YOU DON’T EVEN BELIEVE WHAT YOU
ARE SAYING.
AND BY THE WAY, IS IT EVEN YOUR
ROLE TO SAY WHO SHOULD WORK AND
WHO SHOULDN’T?
WHY CAN’T ONE STORE BE OPENED
BUT NOT ANOTHER.
AS DEMOCRATS LOOK TO CRUSH SMALL
BUSINESS, TARGET, COSTCO, HOME
DEPOT AND AMAZON AND THE BIG BOX
COMPANIES ARE ALL THRIVING.
SMALL BUSINESSES SELLING THE
SAME ITEMS ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
OPEN.
BUT YOU KEEP SAYING LISTEN TO
THE SCIENCE.
WHAT SCIENCE?
WHERE ARE THE NUMBERS THAT
SUPPORT THE CLOSING OF ALL
RESTAURANTS IN NEW YORK, NEW
JERSEY AND CALIFORNIA WHEN THERE
IS ONLY A 1.4% COVID SPREAD.
YOU KEEP TRYING TO CLOSE SCHOOLS
AND GET MORE MONEY FOR THE
UNIONS, AND KIDS RARELY GET IT
AND RARELY SPREAD IT.
YET YOU HYPOCRITES ALLOW SOCIAL
DISTANCE TO DISAPPEAR WHEN
SO-CALLED SOCIAL JUSTICE IS IN
YOUR AGENDA.
WHERE IS THE SMALL BUSINESS
JUSTICE?
WHERE IS THE RIGHT TO THE
PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS.
WHERE IS THE RIGHT OF THE LITTLE
MAN TO COME NEAT THIS COUNTRY?
-- TO COMPETE IN THIS COUNTRY?
WHY IS McDONALD’S ALLOWED TO
OPEN BUT NOT MY LITTLE BURGER
JOINT.
TELL ME ABOUT THE GUY WHO HANDS
ME MY BURGER THROUGH THE WINDOW
AND HE TOUCHES HIS HANDS TO HIS
GLASSES, AND WAS THE MASK ON THE
WHOLE TIME, AND IF HE NEEDS, DID
THE MASK SLIP OFF?
HOW LONG HAVE HIS GLOVES BEEN
ON.
DID HE WIPE HIS HANDS ON HIS
PANTS OR APRON?
DID HE COUGH INTO HIS SLEEVE?
WHO ARE YOU KIDDING?
THE ONE THAT TAKES THE CASE IS
OCASIO-CORTEZ WHO AT AGE 30 TOOK
THE VACCINE.
I CALL IT THE TRUMP VACCINE.
SO MANY DEMOCRATS SAID THEY
WOULDN’T TAKE IT IF IT CAME OUT
OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
BUT THERE THEY ARE JUMPING TO
THE FRONT OF THE LINE.
YET THESE FEDERAL POLITICIANS
CONSIDER THEMSELVES VITAL AND
ARE THEREFORE AMONG THE FIRST TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE IMMUNIZATION.
HEALTHY MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
MANY OF THEM YOUNGER THAN 4.
>>THAN --
THAN 40 PUSHING AMERICANS TO THE
CURB AS THEY BULLY THEIR WAY TO
A VACCINE.
THE SAME BULLIES WHO GOT A
PAYCHECK AND DIDN’T GIVE A DAMN
WHETHER YOU GOT ONE.
MY FRIEND AND DOCTOR IS 73.
HE SPENT HIS LIFE CARING FOR
OTHERS.
HE HAS A COMPROMISED IMMUNE
SYSTEM.
HE’S NOT GOING TO GET THE
VACCINE FOR MONTHS AFTER
CONGRESS, ESSENTIAL WORKERS
WHICH INCLUDE THE GARBAGE
COLLECTORS AND THE TRUCKERS.
HE’S HOPING AND HIS FAMILY IS
HOPING HE CAN HANG ON LONG
ENOUGH TO GET IT.
I HAVE AN IDEA, AOC.
YOU TALK THE BIG TALK ABOUT
EQUALITY, MINORITY JUSTICE AND
INJUSTICE.
YOU SHOULD BE THE LAST IN LINE
TO GET THE VACCINE.
YOU GUYS DID NOTHING FOR THE
LAST SIX MONTHS BUT PLAY
POLITICS IN THE RUN-UP TO THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
WHY WEREN’T YOU PROTESTING WITH
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS WHO KNOW
IN THEIR HEARTS THEY WILL NOT
SURVIVE ANOTHER SHUTDOWN.
WHO KNOW THERE IS NO ONE
FIGHTING FOR THEM.
YOU DON’T HAVE TO BE A GENIUS TO
KNOW THAT IF LOCKDOWNS ACTUALLY
WORKED, THEY WOULDN’T HAVE TO
KEEP LOCKING US DOWN.
HAVE YOU EVEN BEEN TRYING TO GET
AMERICANS TO AMERICANS, A SIMPLE
STRAIGHT BILL, YOU CONDESCENDING
PATRONIZING HOLIER THAN THOU WHO
USE YOUR TAX DOLLARS TO PAY
YOURSELVES WHILE WE WAIT AND BEG
YOU TO GET OUR MONEY FOR OUR
FAMILIES.
NOW TO GET A VACCINE TO SURVIVE.
AFTER YOU GET THE VACCINE.
AND THEN YOU GET PAID.
YOU SHOVEL DOWN $500 MEALS AT
THE FRENCH LAUNDRY IN
CALIFORNIA.
FAMILIES ARE WAITING IN LINE FOR
FOOD ACROSS AMERICA.
YOU ARE DISGUSTING, YOU ARE AN
EMBARRASSMENT TO THE PEOPLE’S
HOUSE.
NOW FOR THE BIG CREW-UP.
HOW DO YOU JUSTIFY TAKING MONEY
FROM AMERICA TO GIVE A FOREIGN
NATIONALS AND SPECIAL INTERESTS
IN A PANDEMIC.
DECEMBER 31 WITH THE INABILITY
TO WORK, TO GET A VACCINE.
YOU ARROGANT POLITICIANS THINK
$600 IS ENOUGH?
YOU WORK IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
IT’S THE PEOPLE’S HOUSE.
YOU PROVE TO SPEND IT ON THIRD
WORLD COUNTRIES WHILE WE ARE IN
A PANDEMIC.
YOU WANT TO GIVE $10 MILLION FOR
JENNER PROGRAMS IN PAKISTAN.
$1.8 BILLION TO THE ASIAN
REASSURANCE INITIATIVE ACT.
AND MAKE SURE FILIPINO STUDENTS
DON’T PLAY HOOKY.
IF YOU CAN’T AFFORD TO TAKE CARE
OF AMERICANS BUT YOU CAN PAY
OTHER COUNTRIES AND SPECIAL
LOBBYISTS.
THEN WE CAN’T AFFORD TO HAVE YOU
IN THE THE PEOPLE’S HOUSE.
YOU HAVE PROVEN YOU ARE
DISLOYAL.
YOU ARE HAVE DISTAIN FOR THE
PEOPLE YOU REPRESENT.
AND IT WILL BE YOUR UNDOING.
TRUST ME ON THAT.
THAT’S MY OPEN.
LET ME KNOW WHAT YOU THINK ON